The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm very
interested in teaching in ways
that really help you learn.
And one of the most
difficult things to learn
is when you have to unlearn
something you believe.
So if you have learned
a concept wrong
in your previous
education and learnings,
your mind is really
reluctant to let go of it.
OK?
And I have a wife who is a
middle school science teacher.
She also has a PhD in biology.
But she really studies
to understand kids
and how they learn.
And MIT students aren't much
different from 6th graders,
to tell you the truth,
when it comes to learning.
None of us are.
But they're just a
little more transparent.
What you can do to help a
person unlearn something they've
learned wrong, the
best time is when
you run into something
called a "discrepant event."
So when you think
you know the answer,
and I'm asking you these
questions, and you're wrong,
really try to figure
out what it is
you believe that
led you to that,
and see if you can undo that
in getting to the answer.
So some of these
concept questions,
if you'd like to talk
about them further,
I think they're great for
discussions in your recitation
section.
Look at Professor Gossard here.
So talk about these
things, and really try
to get to the bottom
of why you perhaps
had a concept that wasn't
quite up to what you needed.
OK.
We're going to move on.
Now we're going to get on
to talking about velocities
in rotating frames.
And by velocities, I
also mean derivatives
of vectors in rotating frames.
Just to give you a quick
reminder of where we started
this conversation,
this is concept
if you have three points-- A,
B, and O in this fixed frame.
This is r A with respect
to O, B with respect to A,
and B with respect
to O, all vectors.
And we're interested
in computing
the velocities of,
say, point B. So we
were talking about the
derivative with respect
to time of this vector.
And we can make it up as a sum
of the derivatives with respect
to time of these
other two vectors.
But now there's a
really important point.
When you're taking
time derivatives,
you have to be
explicit about what
it's with respect to--
what frame of reference
you're talking about.
In this case we want to know
the velocity with respect
to this reference frame.
So both of these
derivatives have
to be taken with
respect to that frame.
Well this one's easy.
This is purely translational.
It has nothing to do
with rotations, or won't.
We're going to think in terms
of having an object out here.
So maybe a rigid body to which
we have attached a rotating
frame at A. And I'll call
this the rotating reference
frame A x prime y prime.
And it might be rotating.
But this point is just the
point with which we describe
the translation of the body.
So this one's pretty easy.
This one's just the velocity
of A with respect to O.
But this one has complications.
And I'm going to do it first,
the answer to this, just
intuitively-- appeal
to your intuition
about why this should be.
So this is my merry-go-round.
And I've set up my
little coordinate system.
This is my A, x prime y
prime coordinate system.
I've stuck my dog
here on the x-axis.
And if he's running
some direction,
he has a velocity with respect
to this reference frame.
If you're here at A, watch
it, and you'll see him moving.
And it will have nothing
to do with the rotation.
You will just see
the dog moving.
And if this is rotating, and
you're sitting there rotating
with it watching the dog, does
the motion of the dog change?
You just see it just
the same way, right?
OK.
So there's one part of the
motion of the dog that's
with respect to
this frame that has
nothing to do with rotation.
OK.
So now let's say in an outside,
and from an outside point
of view, if we
measure the velocity
of the dog with respect
to point A-- that's
the one you can see-- and
to observer outside says
what's the velocity of
dog with respect to A,
will the answer differ
if there's rotation?
OK.
Now, what we're
going to find out
is that there's actually
two contributions.
So the dog running with
respect to this merry-go-round
is one contribution
to the velocity.
There's another contribution
that comes from the fact
that you're sitting
out there watching,
and you see definitely the dog
move when the thing rotates,
right?
OK.
And if we only do that,
if the only rotation--
and we'll do a case where
the dog's not running, just
sitting still--
what's the velocity
of the dog with respect to
point A due to the rotation?
I mean you've done lots
of problems like this.
This is just pure
rotation problem.
You know the angular
rate-- theta dot, or omega.
What's the velocity of
point B if point A is fixed
and this thing rotates?
r omega.
You all know that.
OK.
And then we'll call the velocity
of the dog relative to point
A due to the fact that he
is moving in this frame,
we'll call that
velocity to the dog.
From the point of view of in the
frame is a different quantity.
They're both vectors, and
you can add them together.
So in fact the
answer-- I'm just going
to give you the answer to this
problem-- the answer to this
is the velocity of
A with respect to O
plus the derivative of r B/A
with respect to time as seen
from within the A
xyz prime frame,
plus a term here
due to rotation.
And we know that the magnitude
of this answer is some r omega.
We know it looks like r omega.
So to interpret this as
meaning the derivative
of this vector-- this thing--
as if you were in the frame.
And that accounts
for the dog running.
This is just the dog running.
And mathematically, I
actually find it easier
to say what this
piece means is this
is the velocity of
the dog with respect
to A with omega equal to 0.
It's the same thing.
This is what you see
if there's no rotation.
That piece.
And this is the
piece with rotation.
But I want you to think
something through here.
Come on.
I'm still learning
how to do this.
OK.
So I have my little
reference frames like this.
I'm going to rotate it in this
direction, which given xyz
ought to be in that direction.
So the rotation rate,
if it's going like this,
I'm going to give
it a constant value,
is that the vector omega is some
omega in the k hat direction,
right?
And I have on this
body-- here's my wheel,
and here's B, and here's A.
And this is my little x-axis,
my x-prime axis.
And it has associated with it
a lowercase i hat unit vector.
And off in this
direction then would
be the y prime with
a j hat unit vector.
OK.
So what's the vector r B/A?
How would you write it in vector
notation in components here?
So this is r B/A
from here to here.
And what's its direction?
AUDIENCE: i hat?
PROFESSOR: i hat.
And is it positive or negative?
So this is the vector.
At some magnitude r B/A in
the positive i hat direction,
the arrow goes,
when you say r B/A,
this is B with respect to
A, the arrow goes with B.
So this, it's
positive r B/A i hat.
And what is the velocity that
we have discovered up here,
the velocity of B
with respect to A as
measured inside of A xyz?
That's this piece here.
In vector terms?
And we've figured out
what its velocity was.
It's some r omega.
The r's r B/A-- the magnitude,
the length of that r.
Clearly got to be this
length right here.
And the omega is given.
So what direction?
You know that the
magnitudes are omega.
What's the direction?
AUDIENCE: j hat?
PROFESSOR: j hat.
OK.
So what we're saying
is the velocity
of B with respect to A as seen
from inside this A frame is
r B/A omega with respect to
O in the j hat direction.
Now this has a k
associated with it.
That has an i
And this has a j
associated with it.
So as a product r omega,
what kind of product is it?
What you know about vectors?
What does it have to be?
Is it a dot product
between omega and r?
Is it a cross product?
I hear somebody
saying cross product.
But what's the order?
So I want you to figure
out-- just deduce
what the vector
notation is that gets
you the right velocity--
the correct velocity--
correct magnitude and
correct direction.
So the answer is
positive r omega j.
AUDIENCE: Omega cross r?
PROFESSOR: Omega.
AUDIENCE: Cross to the r?
PROFESSOR: Omega cross r.
So I hear one person, omega
with respect to O cross r B/A.
And these are now both vectors.
Anybody else?
So if we just think
about unit vector,
actually, let's check it.
This is k hat direction.
This was i hat direction.
And k cross i is positive j.
So that works.
So in general-- this is,
in fact, the correct answer
in general-- is that this term
here is omega with respect
to O cross r B/A. You're
going to use that a lot.
So to summarize, then--
while that's coming down,
the velocity of this dog
in a stationary frame where
A is stationary for a moment is
entirely due to the rotation,
and it's omega cross r B/A.
And now if the dog starts
to run with respect to
this reference frame,
he has some velocity,
which is the other piece
is velocity of B with
respect to A as seen from A--
or as you would compute,
you'd just set momentarily,
omega equal to zero.
And finally then, the
total formula for velocity.
So the velocity
of B with respect
to O-- some point on a
rotating reference frame--
is the velocity of
the frame plus--
I won't write it as
a derivative now.
Plus the velocity
of the point, but as
seen from the point of view
of somebody in the frame,
plus omega with respect
to O cross r B/A.
So this is an important formula.
You're going to use it a lot.
Couple of subtle points in here.
This one-- this thing from as
seen from inside the frame.
It's also the partial
derivative of r B/A with respect
to t when omega with
respect to O equals zero.
That's another way to say this.
And this term is
another subtlety.
I was careful to write
with respect to O. Yes?
AUDIENCE: To make sure I'm not
confused here on this vector
right there.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That leftmost term
is the middle one there?
Or the right one?
PROFESSOR: So this was
when we were working
with just the velocity due
to the motion of the dog
due to rotation
plus-- actually this
was rotation-- what did I say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
experiments.
That the term on the
left is the motion
that you can see from the frame.
From the right is
the rotation that you
don't see in the [INAUDIBLE],
but needs to be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And I can't remember
how I got to this point.
But I think I was making
a couple of points,
and rammed them together.
So this is the correct.
Don't focus on this.
This is the summary.
This thing is now
rotating, and translating,
and the dog's running.
And I want you to be
able to write down
the total velocity
of the point B
as seen from a fixed reference
frame fixed on the ground.
This is with respect to O.
It has three
terms-- the velocity
of A, the velocity of the
dog relative to the body
it's on here, and
finally, the component
of the velocity--
contribution of the velocity
that you see that's
due to the rotation.
Now this turns out to be
a really powerful formula.
It's a generalization.
It's a special case of
a very general formula.
Let me catch up
in my notes here.
Because the following
statement is true.
So the time derivative
of any vector
that's defined in
a rotating frame
is given by-- and we'll
call it just some vector
A. It might be, for
example, angular momentum.
In fact we'll use
this formula a lot
when talking about
angular momentum.
The time derivative
of this vector A--
whatever it represents--
position, velocity,
angular momentum-- as seen from
a reference frame xy-- O xyz,
reference frame O-- is made
up of the derivative of A from
inside the frame plus--
So it's the same thing.
This was the derivative of r
B/A. Has two pieces-- the piece
that came from the dog
running and the piece that
comes from rotation.
Any vector, this piece is true.
It's the derivative
of the vector
inside the frame in which it's
defined plus omega with respect
to the reference frame you want
the derivative in cross A. Very
powerful formula.
This now is covered in a
couple of different places
in the readings, and
in the handout that's
posted called "Kinematics."
So you should read
by now the portion
of the kinematics thing,
at least on velocities.
The second half of
that kinematics handout
is about acceleration.
So we're going to
use this formula
to go from velocity
to acceleration.
I saw a couple hands up.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what is the
difference between O sub
xyz and A sub xyz?
Where are they [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is a
merry-go-round on a train,
and you're looking down on it.
And the train can move.
And we fixed to the
ground, not moving,
a reference frame we call O.
And I want to know in this case
the velocity of the
dog running around
on this merry-go-round
with respect to O.
It's the sum of three
vector contributions--
the velocity of the
train, the velocity
of the dog with respect to
the merry-go-round-- this
is velocity of the train.
This is with respect
to the merry-go-round.
And this is the velocity
that you see out there.
So you're sitting in O. You
are in this fixed frame.
Which brings up another
subtle point about velocities
and inertial frames.
If you are at any fixed
point in an inertial frame--
you don't have to be
at O; you can be right
where you are-- this
term is always the same.
The velocity of this moving
object relative to the frame
is the same to any
observer in the frame--
any fixed observer in the frame.
OK?
And finally, the u.
But the u, the part
of the contribution
to the velocity due to the
rotation of this thing,
you can see it from
out there, right?
It moves.
Well, the rotation
contribution is this.
The dog running around is this.
And the movement of the
train is the first term.
OK?
All right.
And this is the general
formula for the derivative
of a vector in a
translating, rotating frame.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] vectors
beyond the [INAUDIBLE] v
of p with respect
to the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm not
following, here.
AUDIENCE: Are any
of the v, v of A,
for example, or v of B
with respect to A, are they
all vectors?
PROFESSOR: These
are all vectors.
And I've gotten
a little careless
about drawing my underlines
when I haven't broken them down
into components.
This is a vector.
And we can do
this, because we're
relying on formulas for
the sums of vectors.
So it's the vector.
There's a vector describing
the velocity of the train.
For example, if it's moving in
the capital I hat direction,
you have to say that.
And this may
actually be the dog.
At the moment you catch
him, the frame's like this.
And let's say he's running
in the y direction.
His direction at
that instant in time
is in the lowercase
j hat direction
relative to this frame, right?
And that j hat
direction has some angle
with respect to
this frame, which
if you want to reduce
these velocities down
to the unit vectors
in the inertial frame,
you can do that.
But you're going
to have to account
for the angles of this reference
frame compared to that one.
So cosine thetas and sine
thetas and that kind of thing.
One important point about
this general expression
for the derivative of a vector
in a rotating frame, which
therefore applies to this
case, because this is just
the specific example of
derivative of a position
vector giving you velocity.
This term and this
term-- these account
for the change in
length of the vector.
So just to keep it real,
in terms of velocities,
you see a velocity
that's due to the fact
that the velocity vector
itself is changing in length.
Or in this case, the r
vector is changing in length,
so the velocity has something
to do with the change in length.
This term is due only to the
fact that it is rotating.
If the dog's not running,
is his position vector
changing in length?
No.
So this term here
comes from taking
this derivative of
the position vector
within the rotating frame.
So this accounts for the change
in length of that position
vector.
This accounts for the rotation.
This term is the same as
seen from in any frame.
This is the subtlety.
This term, you get the same
answer if you see it from here.
This velocity,
this contribution.
The dog's speed with respect
to this frame it's in
is the same to you out
there in the fixed frame
as it is to somebody
sitting here
in the frame moving with him.
Important point.
It'll become more important
as you do problems.
You need to remember
that doesn't matter
where you're calculating.
You're given the
velocity of the dog
in this frame, and
little i j k components,
it is in magnitude exactly
the same velocity as you would
see it in the fixed frame.
But then you just have to
account for the right unit
vectors and so forth.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is
the same as the frame,
but the direction is changing?
PROFESSOR: The direction is
the same in any frame also.
It's just that you have
to decide which unit
vectors to represent it in.
And when you're in
this frame, it's
easiest to represent it
in little i j k, right?
But if you're in
the fixed frame,
you may want to actually know
the velocity in the fixed
frames unit vectors, and there's
just geometric conversions
that'll give you that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if theta is like
a function of time [INAUDIBLE]
how would you use those?
Does it just work the same way?
PROFESSOR: So she says if
theta is a function of time,
if you were trying to convert--
this dog's running in the y
direction, which is going in
the master frame over there,
is going to have a component
in the negative capital I hat
and positive capital J
hat direction, right?
And you could break down--
let's say his velocity vector is
like this-- you could break it
down into a component that's
parallel to the
ground, and a component
perpendicular to the ground.
And those then would be
in that reference frame.
You've all, I would think,
have done some problems
using polar coordinates.
And the conversion between
x and y and r and theta
is you used cosine
thetas and sine
thetas to compute it, right?
So read that handout
on kinematics,
because it proves this
formula by doing just that.
It puts everything
in terms of thetas
that are functions of time.
And it's kind of a
long, painful process,
but you can do
that, grind it out,
and you will then, when
you assemble the terms,
you end up with this.
And once you know
this formula, it's
far, far easier
than to calculate
all this in terms of
thetas and theta dots,
and sines and cosines.
OK?
All right.
That's good.
That's important stuff.
We're going to make great
use of these formulas
over the rest of the term.
So I'm going to just take
a break from kinematics.
It's time to talk a little
bit about Newton's laws,
because we really want to be
able to do dynamics problems.
And so this has been about
describing the motion.
And now we want to talk about
the laws on which we depend
in order to be able
to calculate things,
and to draw, write equations
of motion and so forth.
So any final questions
about kinematics?
Because I'm going
to change topics.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So for that equation
to the [INAUDIBLE], then
the acceleration of
[INAUDIBLE] with respect
to the reference frame,
that's [INAUDIBLE]
is just zero, right?
PROFESSOR: You're asking
about acceleration, now?
Do you really mean?
Is that what you mean?
Because I haven't talked
much about acceleration.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
because also [INAUDIBLE] x
to the velocity change.
PROFESSOR: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this equation
is true of any vector.
This is basically
vector calculus.
It's true of any vector
in a rotating frame.
It's time derivative with
respect to a fixed frame.
It is the derivative you
would see in the rotating
frame, which is just the
change of length of the vector,
and the part due to the fact
that you are making it rotate.
And we'll do examples of this,
I promise you, very soon.
So you'll see how it's applied.
OK?
OK.
So let's do a quick
review of Newton.
So Newton's Laws.
He had three of them.
And we're all pretty
familiar with the second.
The first, though, is
called the law of inertia.
And basically, the
first law says,
if an object is motionless
in the absence of forces,
what happens?
Stays motionless.
Or, if it's at some
constant velocity
in the absence of forces it
stays at constant velocity,
right?
So these have been stated
many ways over the years.
I'm just going to try to come up
with short ones for the board.
So in the absence of
forces an object--
a particle-- moves
with constant velocity.
In fact, Newton only talked
about motions of particles,
not as in little tiny things.
Not about rigid bodies that
have finite dimensions.
He thought of the planets,
appropriately, as particles.
Second law.
Second law, I won't
write it all out.
But basically F equals ma.
Their vectors equals
the time derivative
of the linear momentum.
That's what we know
as the second law.
The sum of all the
external forces
equals the mass times
the acceleration.
Another statement
of the second law.
OK?
So you know that one.
That's the one you're
most familiar with.
Third one.
What's the third one?
AUDIENCE: Every action has an
equal and opposite reaction.
PROFESSOR: So every action has
an equal and opposite reaction.
And I'm going to draw
a picture for this one.
So here's a particle.
Here's another particle.
This is particle 2.
Particle 1.
There's a force on
this particle that's
the force on 2 due
to the presence of 1.
They've each got a little
gravity, little attraction
from one another.
And this one has a force on
particle 1 due to particle 2.
OK?
They could be two planets.
And basically what he said
is that for every action,
there's an equal and
opposite reaction.
That means that f 21
equals minus f 12.
And this is called
the strong form
of Newton's third law,
which the forces are equal,
opposite, and collinear.
They actually point exactly
opposite one another.
And this is true of
mechanical systems.
You get some rather
interesting subtleties
when you get into
electromagnetic fields,
and charged particles,
and things like that.
So you have to think
really carefully.
But for the mechanical
systems, the strong form
will suit us just fine.
OK.
Those are the three laws.
Newton made one major
condition for those to be true.
What is the assumption that
must be satisfied for these laws
to be true?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] an
inertial reference frame?
PROFESSOR: I hear "an inertial
reference frame," right?
And that's what he assumed.
You have to be in an inertial
frame for these statements
to be true.
So then what I want to spend
a few minutes talking about
is basically what's
an inertial frame.
Because that's
going to be really
important in this subject.
When you start getting on
things that move and rotate,
things sometimes
are not inertial.
So I'm going to ask
you a quick question.
So a reference frame.
So we had our fixed frame up
there, sitting on the ground,
here on the Earth.
Is the Earth an inertial
reference frame, standing
here observing things?
I want a show of hands.
I really want some
participation here.
How many of you think
Earth's an inertial frame?
Raise your hand.
It's true.
How many think it's not true?
How many think it depends?
On what?
AUDIENCE: What you
are focusing on.
PROFESSOR: What the problem is.
He says it depends on
what you're focusing on.
So it really depends on
the sizes of the forces
and the motion
you're interested in.
Can you give me an example
in which the Earth cannot be
assumed to be an inertial frame?
Practical example?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Not practical.
PROFESSOR: Impractical.
AUDIENCE: The rotation
of Earth is slowing?
The rotation of the
Earth is slowing?
PROFESSOR: Rotation of
the earth is slowing.
That's interesting.
To account for that, you would
definitely not be able to just
to assume we're inertial.
But what's an everyday
example of where,
if you're trying to solve
a problem in this field,
you couldn't make this
inertial assumption?
AUDIENCE: Rotation
of the planets?
PROFESSOR: Well, no,
for the most part,
you could get most of it.
But, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
the weather, really,
because the wind currents,
or like the ocean
currents are affected by the
fact that the Earth is round.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's a good one.
In order to account
for the circulation
you have to take into
account the Earth's motion.
Let me give you an example.
Clocks.
Pendulum clocks.
Does the speed of
a clock change?
Is it different at high
noon from midnight?
What do you think?
Yes or no?
How many think that
the actual speed
of a clock-- the
length of a second--
would be different at
noon on the Earth--
a pendulum clock--
from midnight?
How many think
that might be true?
It's different?
How many don't believe
that it would be true?
How many just not
raising their hands?
Come on you guys.
Let's get with it.
OK.
So the effective
acceleration of gravity
that that pendulum feels
is different at noon
from midnight.
And one reason is because at
noon the sun's pulling away
from the surface of the
Earth, and at midnight
the sun's gravity is pulling
in the same direction
as toward the
center of the Earth.
The total effective
gravitational
pull that the
pendulum field changes
due to the rotation of
the Earth, what it feels.
The sum of the forces
on the pendulum
includes the Earth's gravity
and the sun's gravity.
And the moon also does this.
So there's daily
variations in the speed
of pendulum clocks just
because of the Earth's
rotation with respect
to the sun and the moon.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that even great
enough to be measurable?
PROFESSOR: So she says,
"Is that even great enough
to be measurable?"
So I have a friend, a
guy named Hugh Hunt.
He's a professor
that teaches dynamics
at Cambridge University.
And he is the keeper of
the Trinity College clock.
Trinity College is
where Newton was.
So he took me to his clock
one day up in this tower.
And it's got about a
two-meter pendulum on it.
And he has got that
clock to run so
that it gains no more
than one second per month.
He's really tuned
it up carefully.
And the key to being
able to do that
is to do things on
monthly averages.
So he's got it tuned
so that over a month
it just barely gains a tiny bit.
But if you measure
it very carefully
over the course of the
day, it has amazingly large
fluctuations.
One of them is due to the
thing I just described.
So if you're really trying to
keep close time, it matters.
OK.
Another one is gunnery.
You're shooting long range.
You're trying to hit a target.
The fact that the
earth rotates, you
will not hit the
target if you don't
account for the effects that are
caused by the Earth's rotation.
And it's one of
the first reasons
that people got
into understanding
the importance of whether or
not it's an inertial frame,
was gunnery in the old days,
from naval ships and so forth.
OK.
So we have three laws.
I want to talk a little bit
about the first and the third.
We're going to use
the second a lot.
So the first law, most
people think of the first law
as being a special case
of the second, right?
It's just when there's no
forces, nothing changes.
But I think the first law
is useful in its own right.
And one of the reasons why
it's called the law of inertia,
it's the law that
allows you to do a test
to discover whether
or not you're actually
in an inertial frame.
Useful to be able to do that.
So I'm going to
give you an example.
And actually, I did want
to ask you a question.
So three possible
answers to this question.
An inertial frame
can-- how to pose this?
If you're in an inertial
frame, can it be accelerating?
frame, can it be rotating?
Or if you're in
an inertial frame,
it can neither
accelerate or rotate.
So which of those three
answers is the best answer
for conditions to be
in an inertial frame?
Non-accelerating,
non-rotating, or both?
How many believe
non-accelerating?
Just non-accelerating?
How many believe in
just not rotating?
How many believe both?
Both is right.
If you are in a frame which
is rotating or accelerating
it's not inertial.
OK.
So just rotation causes
it not to be [INAUDIBLE].
So let's test that.
I'm going to pick
two cases quickly.
Let's use this law
of inertia to set up
a test to see if a couple
different frames are
in fact inertial.
So I've got a cart here.
And I'm sitting
here-- or you are.
We're sitting on the cart.
And this cart is accelerating.
Acceleration of A
with respect to O
is, I'll call it a naught I hat.
This cart's accelerating in
that way, that direction,
the positive I hat direction.
OK.
Now I'm sitting here on the
cart-- not very sensitive.
And I want to test whether or
not I'm in an inertial frame.
So let's pretend this cart,
I've got an air table there,
frictionless table.
And I've got a hockey puck.
And I set it down on
the frictionless table
and let it go.
What happens?
What do I observe?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the puck
will accelerate, you're
saying, towards me, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Hmm.
It'll move.
So she says the puck will move
towards you if you let it go.
So is that an indication
of whether or not
you're in an inertial frame?
So the test-- this
is first law, now.
So the test-- if
you're in this frame,
and you want to know whether or
not this is an inertial frame,
and I claim you can set
this puck out there,
if you're in an inertial
frame, what should it do?
Not move.
If it moves, there's
something going on.
Something fishy, right?
OK.
So the acceleration--
and we'll call
the puck at B. So
the acceleration of B
with respect to O-- and
there's no rotation here.
So the acceleration of
B with respect to O,
it can be written as
the acceleration of A
with respect to O, plus
the acceleration of B
with respect to A.
Now this is O here.
This is an inertial frame.
And if it's an inertial
frame, and there
are no forces in the x
direction acting on this puck,
then I'm going to say that the
sum of the forces on that puck
equal zero.
And therefore, what can I
say about the acceleration
of the puck?
What's the acceleration of
the puck as seen from O?
It's gotta be zero.
If no forces-- so the summation
of the forces with respect
to this O frame in
the x direction,
if there's zero, that
implies the acceleration of B
with respect to O
is got to be zero.
Knowing that, I can now solve
for the acceleration of B
with respect to A.
And that's going
to be minus the acceleration
of A with respect to O.
And that's minus a naught I hat.
So you are correct in
saying that it moves.
But it actually accelerates.
From your point of view, what
you see sitting there in A,
you were going to
see this accelerate
in the opposite direction.
And that's a dead
giveaway that you're not
in an inertial frame.
OK.
Come on.
So a little harder problem.
Now we've got our
merry-go-round.
OK.
And it's fixed.
Not on the train.
It's just sitting here.
But it can spin.
And you're sitting
at A. So you're
up above this merry-go-round
looking down on it.
And it's rotating.
Out there you're in
an inertial frame.
But now you come over to
here, and you sit right here
at the center.
And if you're right
at the center,
you might not actually
feel a thing, right?
And there's no windows.
So this could be a spaceship
out there, slowly rolling over.
So you're sitting
inside of this system,
no windows, right at the
center, can't feel a thing.
And I want you to
construct a test-- be
using the first law-- that'll
tell you whether or not
you're in an inertial frame.
What might you do?
AUDIENCE: Set a ball down
on the ground [INAUDIBLE]
roll off to the edge.
PROFESSOR: All right.
He says set a ball
on the ground,
and see if it rolls
out to the edge.
Right?
See if it moves.
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE]
is this [INAUDIBLE]
under the effect of gravity,
or is there [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's really
make it a merry-go-round.
So there's gravity.
So I want gravity
to be useful here.
It keeps the thing
on the surface.
Doesn't just go drifting off.
So yeah, let's say
we have gravity.
The axis is vertical.
You're sitting here, but
you can't see outside,
and you want to do this test.
So do you agree if
you set the ball down,
you might learn something?
OK.
So you set the ball down.
And you're here watching.
And here's the ball.
And let's say you've got
a ball, and you actually
have a string on the ball.
Set it out there.
So initially you've got
this ball out there.
And you're sitting
here at the center.
And this merry-go-round's
going round and around.
What can you sense
that tells you
that you're not in
an inertial frame,
if you're holding
onto this string?
Does the ball
move, first of all?
Would the ball move
if I'm sitting here
hanging onto the string,
and I set it out there
and set it down?
No, it won't move.
But what do you
feel in the string?
Tension in the string.
OK.
So now you've got
indication number one
that there's something fishy.
OK.
Now you let go of the string.
What should happen?
So you [INAUDIBLE] go out.
All right.
But now I'm going to ask you
a little harder question.
What direction should the ball
travel in once you release it?
AUDIENCE: Radially outwards.
PROFESSOR: Radially outwards.
I have one shot at
radially outwards.
Any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: From
your point of view,
it wouldn't seem to
go in a straight line.
It would seem to
curve off to one side.
PROFESSOR: So I
have one postulate
that it will curve-- it will
go away and curve off, right?
Which way would it curve?
So you're saying not radially.
You say it's going to curve.
AUDIENCE: Opposite direction
that you're spinning.
PROFESSOR: Opposite to the spin.
He says it will curve
opposite to the spin.
AUDIENCE: But only from
your point of view.
PROFESSOR: This
is from the point
of view on the merry-go-round.
Point of view off
the merry-go-round,
might be easier to reason this.
So now you're up above the
merry-go-round in an inertial
frame, up above this
merry-go-round, just
looking down, like sitting up in
a tree and looking down on it.
What do you see?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], but if
you're on the merry-go-round
then you [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
So this is an argument for if
you're on the merry-go-round,
you'll see radial motion.
If you're in the tree,
you'll see the curve.
So we're going to do--
AUDIENCE: I would like
to retract my statement.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right.
I think we'd better
take a vote here.
So the possible answers are
from-- how do we frame this?
From an inertial frame,
looking down on it,
answer A is it will
go in a curved path.
Answer B is it will go in
a straight, radial line.
Answer C is it does--
any other guesses?
No other guesses.
So it's the only two choices.
It curves, or it goes in
a straight, radial line.
So how many vote for-- and
everybody has to participate.
How many vote for it goes
a straight radial line?
Let's have it.
Straight out radial line
from the point of view
of the fixed reference frame.
OK.
A goodly number.
How many from the point of view
of that fixed frame, looking
down on it, will see it curve?
How many vote for that?
And how many didn't vote?
Those are don't knows, huh?
All right.
So A and B are wrong.
A and B are dead wrong.
And you could have
figured out what
the answer is if you went
right back to basics, back
to Newton's Laws.
When the string is released, the
sum of the forces on the object
are what?
In the direction
that it can travel.
Still got gravity
pushing on it, but it
can't go in that direction.
So if you did a
free body diagram,
what are the forces in that
horizontal [? direct ?] plane
that it's sitting on?
I hear centrifugal force.
I hear frictionless.
Let's make the
table frictionless
so it can easy to move.
No friction.
I hear centrifugal force.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: He says zero.
AUDIENCE: There's
the force that you
get from tangent of
[? to ?] less perpendicular
to the radial direction.
PROFESSOR: What's perpendicular
to the radial direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it had
to [INAUDIBLE] B traveling
[INAUDIBLE] at one point had
to have [INAUDIBLE] force
with tangential to the circle.
PROFESSOR: So you were the
one that provided that for us.
You're on the merry-go-round.
You set it out there,
and held the string.
You set out there
in some radius r.
And so because when you set it
down, you're already turning.
So you just set it down with
respect to the merry-go-round.
It's not moving.
You just set it down.
OK?
What are the forces-- so just
draw the free-body diagram.
Here's this puck.
And you've released the string.
And you got mg downwards,
and you have a normal force
upwards.
And you have no friction.
And I hear centrifugal
force, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well,
that was a guess.
Somebody said straight
out, and the answer is no.
And we're going
to figure it out.
First of all, we've got
to sort out the forces.
Well, what are the
forces on this thing?
So I heard centrifugal force.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think the only
force is the centrifugal force.
But there was a velocity
that's not caused by the force.
So the velocity that you got was
velocity that you told us about
that [INAUDIBLE]
that starts out--
PROFESSOR: You set it down.
And once you set it
down, it's there.
And then?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, your
initial velocity
from setting it out there.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The change in
direction-- the force only
change direction of the ball.
But once the string cuts,
and the direction no longer
changes, and the ball only
goes the direction that
is tangential to the circle.
PROFESSOR: All right.
The man has it right.
You probably couldn't hear him.
He says that when
you let it go, it
goes tangential to the circle.
And that's true.
The forces on in
this direction--
in the horizontal direction--
once you release the object,
there are no forces.
Centrifugal force is a
construction of convenience
called a fictitious force.
And we'll talk about that later.
It is not a real force.
It as a result of
an acceleration.
And it's the result of
the acceleration when you
are making it go in a circle.
There is indeed--
that tension is
what some people call the
centrifugal force holding it
there.
But once you release it,
that's no longer there.
And if there are
no external forces
acting on the object in the
horizontal direction, what's
the mass times the acceleration?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Therefore
what's the acceleration?
Zero.
And its velocity.
What's its velocity at
that moment in time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Omega.
R omega.
So you have an R omega velocity.
It's tangential to the motion.
So let's make this my
little x, and this my axes
attached to the merry-go-round.
This thing is moving
in the j-hat direction
at R B with respect to A
in the j-hat direction.
That is the velocity
of B with respect to A
at the moment you release it.
OK?
So it had better run off
tangential to the circle
at the moment of release.
So let's test it.
Now I want you to be my
quality control person.
If I smack somebody with
this, I'm going to hurt them.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Squeeze it.
Soft and harmless, right?
OK.
So when should I
release it if I want
to hit the MIT sweatshirt
sitting up there?
When it's out here, right?
I'll see if I can do it.
All right.
I'd better not try it again.
I probably can't do
it twice in a row.
AUDIENCE: But that
was a straight line.
PROFESSOR: It was
in a straight line.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So one of the guesses was--
PROFESSOR: Radial straight
line was one guess.
This is?
AUDIENCE: Tangential
straight line.
PROFESSOR: Got it.
So this tangential straight
line is the right answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the velocity
is equal to the
radius [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I can't
quite hear you.
AUDIENCE: Here it says that
the velocity of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, I left
out the omega, didn't I?
Sorry about that.
So it is omega is the
result of omega cross r B/A.
So it's omega with respect to
O, r B/A in the j direction.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
person on the merry-go-round
does not see that.
PROFESSOR: Ah.
So actually I
almost forgot this.
She is talking about
what does the person
see on the merry-go-round?
What do you actually see
on the merry-go-round?
Certainly doesn't go radial.
We've proven that, right?
But the person on
the merry-go-round,
is you're turning, and
this thing is going off
in a straight line with
respect to the fixed frame,
and you're turning away from it.
So looking down on
it, I release it here.
It goes off in that direction.
Your point of observation,
you see it here.
But now a short time later, when
you've rotated to this point,
and you're just
keeping your eye on it,
you see this thing
start to move.
But this is the spot
that it was sitting on,
which is now moved to here.
But its position is now there.
You see it moving away from you.
And as you get up to,
say, here, then it
will have moved out
a radius this far.
Well, actually it's not--
you don't know how fast
you're-- well, you're actually
going exactly the same speed it
is.
So you've gone the
arc length here.
It's gone a quarter of a
circle out to about there.
Same point right here.
But now you see it as
being going off like that.
To you, it's hooking off
in the direction opposite
to the direction of rotation.
So the young man up there
who described that early on
was exactly right.
So from your point of view,
it goes mrrmm, like that.
And then if you go
all the way around,
it'll appear to come back.
It'll be further
away, but you'll
be back down to the point
where you see it released.
So it'll look like it goes
from your point of view.
OK.
Good one.
OK, we've got a
few minutes left.
I want to do something really
important with the third law.
So the first law's
actually pretty important
and very handy.
The second law, we're going
to make lots of use of.
So I want to talk a minute
about the third law.
The third law is responsible
for a law that we use,
or an application that
we use all the time.
And let's see how
this works out.
So Newton's third
law is the one that
says F 21 is equal to F 12.
So we have these two particles.
And I called them 2 and 1.
And I'll give this
one mass 1, mass 2.
And I'm going to say
second law tells me
that the sum of the forces,
vectors, external forces, on 2
is-- and this one,
let's say it has things,
active forces acting on it.
F i's.
And it has this little f 21.
So the forces here are
the external forces
that are vectors, plus f,
[? some ?] of the forces on 2.
So forces on 2 due to 1.
That's external influence
of the other particle.
OK?
And this had better be equal
to m 2 a 2, I'll call it.
And with respect to some
fixed, some inertial frame.
So the sum of all these external
forces on that particle 2
had better be equal to the
mass times the acceleration
of particle 2.
And the same thing can
be said about particle 1.
So I've really
confused things here.
There's 2, and there's 1.
Boy.
OK.
Guys, help keep me honest here.
So now that we can say
the sum of the forces on 1
is equal to these external
applied forces, plus f 12--
the force caused
by the other body.
And those had better
equal to m 1 a 1/0.
OK.
And these are also equal to the
time derivative of m 2 v 2/0.
That's the momentum, the time
derivative of the momentum.
It's fixed mass, so it's
just the derivative velocity
gives the acceleration.
So these are clearly
the same formula.
And this is a time derivative
of m 1 v 1 with respect to O dt.
And we call that
P 2 dot, P 1 dot.
So these are statements
that are applying second law
to each of these particles.
So if I want to compute the
total momentum of the system.
So the linear momentum, the
total momentum of the system
is going to be P 1 plus P 2.
They're vectors.
And I want to take
the time derivative
of that total momentum.
Just the time
derivative of a sum
is the sum of the
time derivatives.
And so I get a P 1
dot plus a P 2 dot.
But I know what those are.
I have expressions for them.
So this is F 1 external
forces plus f 12
plus the F 2 external
forces plus f 21.
These two things.
This one plus this
one, basically,
is the sum of the two time
derivatives of the momentum.
But what's the sum of
this term and that term?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
And that then allows
you to say that this
is the sum of the external
forces on a system is
equal to the time rate of
change of the linear momentum
of the system.
OK.
And that's basically
this statement.
And it has nothing to
do with internal forces.
And this allows you
to say that the time
rate of change of the linear
momentum of a rigid body,
for example.
So a rigid body is
made up of a whole mess
of different particles.
You could separate this into a
whole bunch of little chunks,
and treat each one of them as a
particle which has connection,
has forces with
particles next to it.
And all those internal
forces-- so these
are the internal forces--
all of those internal forces
are equal and
opposite and cancel.
So it's really
the third law that
allows you to say if you
have a system of particles
that the time rate of
change of the total momentum
of the system is zero if there's
no external forces acting
on it.
And that's where you get the
conservation of momentum--
the law of conservation
of momentum.
OK.
That's a consequence
of the third law.
OK.
So you have a homework problem
that has just about this.
You have a bunch of particles.
m 1.
m i.
r 1 with respect to O.
r i with respect to O.
And you have all these
particles out there.
And I want to find
the center of mass
of this group of particles.
So the center of
mass is a vector.
And let's just say it's here.
So I'm looking for r
G with respect to O.
So it's a quantity
that I defined--
r G with respect to O-- times
the summation of the m i's.
So I'm postulating there's
a place out there that if I
multiply it by the sum of the
m i's, I get the same answer
as if I summed the m i r i/O's.
And I'm going to define
the center of mass
as r G with respect to O is
the summation of each particle
times its position
vector divided
by the sum of the
masses, which is just
the total mass of the system.
OK?
And that's a definition
of center of mass.
And this is a vector.
And these are vectors.
OK?
So that's all there is
to the center of mass.
And if I take a time
derivative of r G/O,
then it's equal to the summation
of the m i times the r i/O's.
But they're timed
derivatives-- and I'm
going to put a dot right
there, so I don't have
to write out d by dt-- over MT.
But that's just the summation of
the individual momenta of each
of the particles over MT.
Very handy little formula.
And if I take another
time derivative,
so I get an r G/O
double dot, then it's
just the summation of
the time derivatives
of the individual
momenta again over this.
So this is a statement.
We move this to the other side.
M T r G/O double dot
equals the summation
of the timed derivatives
of the individual momenta.
And that's the total
momentum of the system
times its timed derivative.
So just from third
law, you can come up
with all of the linear
momentum formulas.
This is a statement
for rigid body.
The mass times the acceleration
of the center of mass.
The total mass of a rigid
body times the acceleration
of the center of mass
is equal to the time
rate of change of the total
momentum of that object.
Very important formula.
You've used it a lot, right?
So I'll tell you a quick story,
and then we'll knock off.
So two, three years ago,
we have doctoral exams
in mechanical engineering.
And in the dynamics oral
exam, we had eight students
a few years ago.
And they were asked to find the
center of mass of an object.
It was just a step
in a harder problem.
And seven out of
the eight students
could not remember
the definition
of the center of mass.
Now they could do Lagrange
equations and nasty dynamics
problems, but they'd
kind of forgotten
some of these really,
really basic things.
So I have one demo
to show you, just
to illustrate center of mass.
So center of mass, we
know how to calculate it.
And this is a rod.
How can I simply find the
center of mass of this thing?
AUDIENCE: Balance it.
PROFESSOR: Balance it.
OK.
Young lady here says
move my fingers.
Where do you think
the center of mass is?
Right in the middle.
OK.
Let's find it.
Should this work, by the way?
You ever done this?
All right, the center
of mass, I ought
to be able to just about
balance this thing there.
So the center of mass
is in the middle.
That's because I cheated.
I put a piece of
steel in this end.
OK?
All right.
But indeed, you might figure out
why is it that I can actually
do this and make it work.
You can do it with a broomstick.
You can do it with any object.
The key is it'll work so long
as the friction coefficients are
the same on both fingers.
It's really easy to find
center of mass that way.
So this got a little
steel weight in the end.
OK.
We're done for today.
And see you on Thursday.